so you have all these swipes and still a
free app yes what's when what do you get
for now so is that what is that gonna
change what are you thinking well so our
core offering that you have right now is
going to always remain free at least at
least that's the plan and next month
actually we're going to release a few
premium features that were totally
excited about it's it's you know it's
it's two things that our users have been
asking for for very long time and we
think there's a great opportunity for us
to introduce these features and and
because we're confident you the values
there and users are willing to pay and
it adds to the user experience where
we're going to charge for any hints and
what that might be um no there are there
are tender hacks as our users call it
you know we always tell us they use
tinder for all different reasons that
were not the original intent for example
when people travel they match with
locals to get recommendations on where
to go and what to do and we think we can
there's an opportunity to enable and
support some of the tender hacks but
actually charge our users for that value
what are something like the most
interesting way ways people using tender
that most kind of like off prescription
that you're surprised by generally I
would say we hear all these cases where
people are using tinder outside of
dating that's that's like but there's
different there's different ways than
that that sort of materializes whether
it's using it to get local
recommendations when traveling or trying
to make friends because you came to new
city or just trying to make friends
period and they're like there's or doing
business we hear all the time that
people are cutting deals on tinder and
and you know whether you're an artist
trying to get your music out there and
try to get fans like the people use
tinder to get more followers on
Instagram by sort of putting there's all
these various hacks and it's great
because you know I think it shows
that we've built an awesome ecosystem
and you know at the root of all of that
I think when you've built a great
product people learn how to leverage it
further than we ever imagined and I
think we're now learning from our users
and those hacks to sort of find the next
opportunities you're rolling it out in
November why is this the time the test
for us was would we do this even if it
didn't make us money is it great for our
users and you know we have this roadmap
and we've only really accomplished like
probably small percentage of what our
ultimate vision is and the things that
we're launching next month are all part
of that that value proposition that we
want to give to our users so it's great
for our users it allows us to make money
to sustain the company so we hope and I
think it's a win-win for everyone I mean
we need we need to keep the company
afloat and and and sort of make money to
reinvest into innovation and and help
build great things that our users are
asking for